[Music]
he studied
architecture both of us and subsequently
she
took a doctoral degree in urban planning
and while me i took
a master's degree in housing and human
settlement it's also an architecture
school
i think probably this is quite a classic
story i think when you are working on
something and then you get bored
and then suddenly you think like okay we
want to do something different you asked
us whether we still love architecture
definitely you know sometimes we
when we walk past a very nice
architectural project we saw like
oh i wonder if yeah you know if we still
doing that
a lot of people asking us about the new
direction
but i mean for both of us it doesn't
feel that it's a completely new
direction
we are still designing for human
so in architecture we are trained to be
sensitive to scale
to proportion to of course function and
color we are also uh trained to be
to be very very sensitive about the
context of the design itself so also in
terms of passions
uh in a way it trains us to be more
sensitive into the larger context
which is uh you know who is it what is
the context of the uh
the work that we are working but we also
look more into the micro details
our universe is at the intersection of
nature and architecture
so this is something that we we like to
do
and for example we have a little bit of
nature
and at the backdrop we actually have a
facet of very
one of the iconic building in singapore
it's
called the colonnade and it's designed
by paul rudolph
so santi created this one uh with the
you know swimming otters frolicking in
the water
i think it really captured the context
of the urban development of singapore
the context of time
design has always been transdisciplinary
and because what design means that you
are solving a certain problem
problems are multifaceted so therefore
the
the solution has to be multifaceted as
well
[Music]
as a designer we have to be very agile
and respect
and flexible in terms of looking what is
happening around us
and of course now with the pandemic it
really underlined the necessity of being
flexible
and being observant basically and we
need to be observant in terms of how
the market preferences change and also
how the customer behavior also change
and i think that's uh very important for
us to be able to always adapt our
product offering
to these kind of changes so how do we
create a fashion design that makes
people
more cheerful feeling more at ease in
terms of
you know the context of the challenges
that we are having